[Music]
hey guys den and Eddie here and we just
got back from playing project cars - or
follow up - project cars that came out a
few years ago and the sequels coming out
in a little while Eddie what did you
think well the first thing you'll notice
if you played the first game you know
all the cars and all the tracks are
unlocked - right from the beginning so
that's a nice little change of pace from
you know some other games that are on
the market if you played the first game
and if you didn't you're you'll
definitely also notice the - it's just
me depth I've never seen anything like
it
it is the simulation of literally an
engine it's crazy
you can customize things like how much
fuel goes into your engine how much air
comes out of your radiator it's insane
it's it's things I didn't know a car
could do you can customize and then when
you just get into all the gameplay
elements - obviously you can tweak the
AI difficulty basically everything under
the Sun that you can imagine for and
also the Sun and the Sun the other of
weather elements include you know I
think there were about 20 that we saw in
there the different sliders you know
everything from you know a beautiful
sunny day to moisture and cold and in a
blizzard so however you want to play
it's gonna be available and you can also
stack those with other elements you can
have up to 4 different weather elements
on a track that it will randomly swap
between which is something that if
you're doing a race that can last for 7
hours which you can also totally do if
you want to race the last for 7 hours
you have a bunch of different weather
the entire time the thing that stood out
to me though was how incredibly
difficult it is
we both struggled I think it's a well to
put it we got better as we play we play
for about 90 minutes maybe two hours
started off very very rough but you know
we kind of knew that going in they did a
simulation game so if you're coming in
from Forza or from any other kind of
arcade style experience you're gonna
have a little bit of a learning curve
here um to put it lightly but you know
once we found that little sweet spot
definitely I mean I could appreciate
yeah the difficulty but we did have fun
with a by the end I think definitely
yeah it's one of those games you have to
practice at which Namco seemed to be
good at like Dark Souls and stuff like
that sorry the more you play it I think
the better you're gonna get but I think
it is definitely for the enthusiast and
car
because there is like I said just so
much to it so we played it on ps4 Pro
but we also played it on PC with three
4k displays in Panorama or whatever you
call that cool massive field of view
mode we're steering wheel with race is
that yeah okay gonna wheel and we've all
found it to be you know quite a bit
easier don't ya
and obviously if you've ever driven a
car it's gonna feel a little bit more
natural than maybe a you know a
traditional game pad would I also think
that that also lends itself to the way
that you have to play this game which is
playing it like you're actually driving
a car yeah if you want to zip around the
corner you're gonna go right into the
wall which we found on every track we
car damage is real yeah yeah so you can
bump a wall and all of a sudden your car
just won't turn anymore so project cars
2 is out this september 22nd and if
you're a car enthusiast who wants to
absolutely tweak every single part of
your car from the tires through to the
sunroof i think this is the game for you
i don't think you gonna find a more
in-depth car simulation out there stay
tuned for more project cars to coverage
at GameSpot we're gonna have a full
breakdown of every single car in the
game and every single track and there
are quite a few
[Music]